companies are already giving up on short
form content last month meta announced
that they will stop offering bonuses to
short form creators why you ask well it
turns out that pushing short form
content actually loses meta money here's
the thing while Instagram we always have
exploded in popularity they're not
exactly stealing market share away from
Tick Tock rather it's stealing market
share away from themselves instead of
scrolling through pictures or the news
feed on Instagram people are now
scrolling through reels this doesn't
sound like a big deal until you consider
that reels are substantially less
profitable than Instagram's other
products in fact according to Zuckerberg
himself people switching to realize as
costing the company 500 million dollars
at every single quarter or two billion
dollars every year and the most ironic
part is that this entire time meta had
been paying creators to make reels so
really they were paying to lose Revenue
no wonder they stopped but it's not just
a matter who is pivoting away from short
form content either Tick Tock themselves
are very much trying to move away in
fact they've been aggressively
increasing their Max video length what
started at 15 seconds grew to 60 seconds
to 3 minutes to now 10 minutes Tick Tock
has even been experimenting with
landscape mode on Android so Tick Tock
is very much headed towards the
direction of becoming the YouTube where
people don't search also it's not like
people search all that much on YouTube
anyway most of the time you just use the
home page to find videos but what
happened why are all these companies
pivoting away from shorts wasn't shorts
the new medium due to ever decreasing
attention spans and the need for
constant stimulation well it turns out
that the answer is Noah while short form
content is great at garnering a lot of
attention in the short term it's not
exactly the best model for companies or
audiences long term Instagram and
YouTubers starting to realize that they
invested way too much money on a low Roi
fad and the tick dog is fighting hard to
not become the next line so here's why
companies got short form content wrong
and why they're already backing off
[Music]
all successful Creator driven platforms
need a strong base of creators this is
why platforms like YouTube and Spotify
have even turned to offering exclusivity
deals like its NFL football or something
so it would be quite an issue if these
platforms were struggling to grow a
Creator base and that's very much the
case with short form content this isn't
to say that Tick Tock and ryoza aren't
able to Garner a bunch of creators
because there is no shortage of that but
what there is a shortage of is loyal
short form creators here's the thing
nine times out of ten people don't start
a posting short form content because
that's what they truly want to do rather
creators start posting short form
content because they see opportunity
they see a gold rush most creators never
find gold but even those who do don't
want to reinvest the profits into mining
for more and simply too risky rather
what they want to do is sell the golden
start a stable business in other words
they want to switch to long-form content
much of this attitude can actually be
explained by the algorithms used to
promote short form content your follower
count on short form content really means
nothing this is why it's such a gold
rush if you start posting today you have
as good of a chance of posting a viral
video as someone with 10 million
followers actually I take that back if a
creator has that many followers they're
probably pretty good at making viral
content but the point is that the
pivotal factor is the content itself not
the follower count while this is great
for new creators it's absolute garbage
when it comes to longevity creators are
forced to always keep up with the latest
trends and to put up something that can
go viral instead of creating content
that's actually impactful and meaningful
this is why you see so many Tick Tock
stars that rise out of nowhere and then
disappear faster than they blew up
recently I was watching an Iraq video
where he trapped 25 tick-tockers inside
his house many of these creators had it
Millions if not tens of millions of
followers so I don't know if it's just
me but I had no idea who any of these
people were let me know down below if
you were in the same boat but anyway
even creators who enjoy making short
prompt content want to switch to long
form because it's simply the smarter
business decision that right there
covers basically 90 of short form
creators the other 10 are actually
already long from creators personally
I'm guilty of this as well a lot of
creators have figured that they might as
well try adapting their regular
long-form content to short form the
mentality is usually if it works great
if it doesn't not a big deal so little
to say no Creator on Tick Tock Instagram
reels or YouTube shorts is really loyal
to said platform for all of them short
form content is really just a
springboard to Garner attention or a
medium to expand their existing
long-form content so when you're trying
to run a Creator driven platform with
such people well let's just say it's
difficult to say the least but building
up a loyal Creator base is just the
first of these platforms worries
[Music]
not only do these platforms have to deal
with flaky craters but they also have to
deal with flaky advertisers the reality
is that no Advertiser really wants to
advertise on short form content this
isn't to say that short form advertising
is always ineffective viejasa for
example has shown time and time again
that short form advertising is not only
effective but can be super lucrative but
with that being said shorts just don't
divide with most brands I mean can you
imagine GE making a tick tock ad about
the refrigerators or Intel making a
Tick-Tock ad about the new I9 processor
it just doesn't feel right now some
Legacy companies are able to pull it off
a notable example that comes to mind is
Coca-Cola but just because they're able
to make effective ads doesn't mean that
they want to advertise on these
platforms the reality is that in most
cases these companies just don't want to
associate with short form content
because they see it as a risk I'm sure
you're familiar with how companies don't
want to associate with the following
content on YouTube well it was Flash
this is basically the entirety of Tick
Tock but let's even put that aside let's
say you're okay with advertising next to
this type of content you still have the
challenge of running a successful ad
campaign while Tick Tock can be great
for promoting products like this it's
not exactly great when it comes to
building General brand awareness and
visibility oftentimes when companies
like apple or Coca-Cola put out an ad
they're not trying to get you to buy
their product they don't even want you
to click on the ad or buy on the spot
rather they just want to build up their
brand of presence this isn't decently
possible on YouTube given that viewers
are forced to watch for 5 or 15 seconds
but on Tick Tock if an added doesn't
depict the viewer's interest within 0.2
seconds they're gonna swipe up this
means that advertisers are forced to
include some sort of a gimmicky hook
which again just doesn't fit with their
brand image and if you don't believe me
you can just look at the numbers for my
usual videos I generally get an ad rate
of four to five dollars per thousand
views for shorts however I generally get
an ad rate of 5 cents per thousand years
this basically indicates that
advertisers are 100 times less likely to
bid on short format slots as opposed to
long form ad slots it also gives a lot
more context as to why creators want to
switch to long form content so badly the
reality is that if you want to make a
living off of short form content you
have to pull in a brain dead amount of
views every single month to make just
five thousand dollars per month for
example you have to pull in a hundred
million views let me phrase that in a
different way you have to reach 1 8 of
the entire world population every single
year just to make 60 Grand at least
creators have the option to do direct
brand deals or promote their own
products for these platforms on the
other hand the only way they make money
is through these ads so even with the
ridiculous skill it's just not all that
profitable so it's no wonder why meta is
losing two billion dollars every single
year by pushing short form content
well unloyal creators and hesitant
advertisers are no doubt a pain in the
neck at least there's some hope with
that as more modern companies start
advertising on short form platforms
outrage should go up which should make
creating short form more worthwhile for
platforms and creators but something
that these platforms can't recover from
is a waning audience the truth is that
people are getting tired of predictable
Tick Tock content and the main reason
for this is that these types of videos
rarely have any substance every single
video is based around a thirst trap or
some sort of gimmick but rarely do they
have any sort of real takeaway or
message this is why people forget about
most shorts within two minutes of
watching it it feels good in the moment
but the feeling doesn't last long but
wait a minute isn't people's attention
spans getting crushed by these platforms
well to be honest I think this effect is
vastly overstated tick tock is it
basically like ice cream people like
eating ice cream they may even eat it on
a daily basis but just because a person
eats ice cream it doesn't mean that
they're suddenly going to stop eating
steak or pizza or burgers or real food
in general in fact if you had the option
of only consuming ice cream or pizza I'm
pretty sure that virtually everyone will
choose Pizza looking back the pandemic
forced most people to stay at home which
led to them snacking away more than
usual but as people return to their
normal lives their social media diet is
also returning to real food and this is
already evident in the stats in 2021
Tick Tock Rose to be the most popular
domain in the entire world but in 2022
Tick Tock fell down to number three as a
Google and Facebook regained their leads
and looking forward it seems like this
trend will only continue as Tick Tock is
looking more and more like Ryan I know
that most of you just remember Vine as a
big failure but find where was actually
super popular for a period of time in
fact at the end of 2015 mine had as many
as 200 million users why did a Vine fail
then you ask well you can take it from
the horse's mouth itself Twitter the
apparent company of Vine was unable and
or unwilling to pay the creators that
made the platform so popular in the
first place this was actually Jack
dorsey's biggest regret but what is Tick
Tock doing well they're unable and or
unwilling to pay the creators that made
their platform so big and as audiences
and creators naturally shift back to
Facebook and YouTube these platforms see
less of a reason to be so aggressive
when it comes to promoting shorts
[Music]
in the end it's not surprising why
companies are backing away from a short
form content the reality is that
creators are just using shorts as a
springboard advertisers don't want to
get involved and audiences are by no
means ditching long form content this
isn't to say that Tick Tock is going to
die like Vine but what has become
abundantly clear is that short form
content is simply an addition to
long-form content not a replacement like
the media often suggests so Mara and
YouTube no longer feel threatened by
Tick Tock if anything it's actually a
tick tock that strives to be more like
meta and YouTube so that they don't end
up like Vine combine this with the
recession and it simply makes no sense
to bet so much on a historically flaky
medium and that's why companies are
already giving up and pulling back on
short form content did you ever buy into
the short form of craze comment that
down below also drop a like if you're
glad that short form content is dying
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community together ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically entered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one